you disobeyed orders acted on your own
impulses and first the lives of millions
of people that's all does it game to you
Shinji don't want to hear your excuses
what was your father think of this he
doesn't care he's not even here now your
father is a very busy man Shinji no he's
not he's probably just somewhere
laughing at the fact that son almost got
killed again
ha ha ha silence everyone in this
organisation is risking their lives
Shinji we all have our roles we have to
learn ok mr. Hikari we will try this one
last time what do you see here it's
Godzilla incorrect it's Godzilla
incorrect it's Godzilla incorrect
[Music]
your mom everyone here just hates me
nobody cares about me I'm the one that
always gets picked on I'm the one that's
enough if you're unhappy and go do
something about it oh yeah well you know
what I'm gonna do
what Shinji what are you gonna do
[Music]
okay new kid I need you to hit me as
hard as you can Dec did the other day so
you need to hit me back I'm not gonna
hit you I can take it so just do it
already I don't want to we need to do
this so we can be friends I don't want
to do it do it I'm not doing it do it no
just grow a pair hit me in the face you
little mama's boy did you just slap me
Rae Ayanami no known family no past
records the girl is just a mystery
interesting way to say she is a
personality of sandpaper what happened
anyway
how'd she get so injured it was during
the unit zero testing phase everything
was going well until something happened
it took her to get off and so my wife
said I'd rather die than spend another
second with you so I was all like ha
joke's on you
you can go die for all I care cuz I've
already made some stupid cloning you
call Dre sounds kind of dangerous
well the commander was still his usual
self relax I got this stop bringing are
you stupid robots
that still doesn't explain how ray got
our injuries well after unit zero would
stop going berserk we had to get ray out
normally we'd send a team to extract her
but the entry plug ceiling it's probably
not as bad as it looks
she ended up breaking most of the bones
in her body Wow how'd she take all this
how do you think ray you're okay to
pilot again right I hope you die in a
fire
that's my girl I just don't get it how
can the commander be so ignorant he
doesn't even understand his own son oh
please that's the way his mind works
he'll probably be calling me up soon
telling me about some new genius plan of
his or something don't say I have a new
genius plan does this one also involve
your son no I heard he didn't come home
last night anyway Shinji ran away again
well stop [ __ ] presses so in the guns
in the movie she was only attacking the
city to find food for her children right
no army distracted her with fish you
know serious and that means you can't be
we can use fish to fake the Angels oh my
god for the last time sir Godzilla is a
fictional monster maybe that's exactly
what the military wants us to think we
are the military perhaps dr. ACOG you
would know what to do that is if she
doesn't want another ride on the kendo
Train what can you get out of your
self-absorbed world for one second
what is our next plan against the Angels
yes
what sorry I was picturing the Gendo
train oh wait
what do you mean if she wants another
ride on the kendo Train you did what's
right I might have slept with him but
yes everyone gets lonely sometimes
he shot you in the arm though I slipped
a little and what you landed on his
penis oh please this coming from the
person who keeps herself occupied with
stupid brainless toys what's that
supposed to mean nice although what's up
I'm expecting pudding at the bathtub I'm
sorry were you talking about Shinji or
the actual dildo you know what forget it
here take these just a stingy to give it
to Ray tomorrow
I don't think he has a courage to take
the initiative not his
virginity the card what else could I
possibly meet so do you always say hello
i pushing people down this is what it
looks like oh well that's good cuz to me
it looks like I'm naked you're lying on
top of me with the what appears to be an
erection my underwear is scattered
everywhere and you've just reached
second base have I missed anything you
could have tried buying me dinner before
trying to have your way with me or at
least start with some small talk oh okay
so nice weather we've been having it was
a joke but you do have your hand on my
breast whoa this is awkward would you
get off me oh yes very much and you can
put away that one inch than you call an
erection it's an embarrassment two
penises worldwide so wait does this get
I just got laid sure why not awesome
now what's that polite thing father told
me to say after sleeping with a girl
sodas [ __ ] want to make me a sandwich
Rhea sorry I just realized you pity it
was a genetic disorder wonder what she
means by that
so does [ __ ] want to make me a sandwich
I am NOT your wife [ __ ] say what now so
I'm sorry about earlier are you mad I
feel like you're a bit mad you're mad
aren't you
you mad Rhea you're bad I'm not mad do I
look mad Oh answer that question in fact
just don't talk to me say ray what do
you think of my father apparently you
don't know what don't talk to me means
he always treats you so nicely I've
heard that father said he always wanted
a son and well I'm a guy that's
debatable so why doesn't he care about
me
what does he want me to do well have you
tried not completely failing at life or
you could always try laughing at your
problems everyone else does I'm kind of
sensing that you don't really like me
that much take it this way if I had a
dick now will be the time I tell you to
stop it are you coming on to me but you
don't want on standby
hey Masato kiss is it a boner
uh if you say I am a boon or one more
goddamn time I will come over and
personally kick your ass
we have visual of the target great what
you tell me target appears to be a thing
what the hell do you mean I think it's a
thing none of you three do anything
useful around here Maya yes the object
is cruising at a steady pace for Central
Java it's constant phase I don't get a
response your quality that makes it
appear like a massive thing analysis
pattern is blue it's it's it's an angel
buddy [ __ ] say it
we are not doing this again
I've a boner what the hell is that again
she said the photonic levels are rising
colonel that order destructions motherly
urges using fish what just don't Colonel
I'm reading a pulse but it's faint
maximize the life support yes ma'am
Colonel whatever she wrote it's an
engineer angel
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]